today's one minute monday is surround
yourself with greatness
the people who you surround yourself
with in your life are important
if you surround yourself with people who
build you up who make you grow who
challenge you to be better
you're going to become great on the
other hand if you surround yourself with
people who just tear you down
who tell you all the reasons why it's
not going to work we tell you that
you're not good enough
i call people like that the little man
if you surround yourself
with people who are the little man then
soon you become the little man
here's a quick example before i do my
filming
i sit down with my connection coach
jenny moon and every week we sit down
and we look at my videos and and she
gives me ideas on how to make them
better and how
how i could challenge myself to take
more risks and if you look
at what's happened in my videos they've
become so much better look at my videos
now
compared to where they were before a lot
of that is thanks to jenny moon i get
off the call with her
and i'm excited i have energy and i'm
ready to go do some videos
surround yourself with great people who
build you up
and you'll build you'll build not only a
great business but you become
a greater person in the process believe
for those of you watching like the video
please give it a thumbs up below let me
know what you think leave a comment
underneath
and if you like the channel subscribe to
get more videos thank you so much and
i'll see you soon
you